so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your host
Carl Smallwood that's Carl Smallwood
that's my real name it's spelled the way
it sounds k a r l s m a w l w o d quite
a mouthful I know nobody ever expects
that from a small wood and today we're
talking about Truman Capote the troubled
author of In Cold Blood and and since we
talking about a celebrated American
author in today's video I thought I'd
bring some books my own personal
collection which people may have noticed
in previous video just sat behind me on
that shelf to go through at various
points throughout the video but before
that and speaking of writers the author
of The Script today's video is based on
Larry holsworth can be found the social
media links below as can I if you are so
inclined but let's get to
it Truman Capote was a darling of the
New York literary set long before he
became an international sensation with
the publication of his novel In Cold
Blood in 196 5 he had written short
stories essays novels and Nolla
contribute to screenplays and provided
critical essays on many other works a
southerner by birth he was a fixture of
the New York Social Scene after he
published in Cold Blood he found himself
in demand for talk shows and public
appearances magazines and newspapers
peppered in for interviews and
commentary and as an openly gay
celebrity he was a rarity for the time
period in which he hob knobbed around
Capote was not only openly gay but
flamboyantly so he hung around with
celebrities and claimed sexual
relationships with celebrities of both
sexes including Errol Flynn and Greta
Garbo attended lavish parties and became
a dominant personage in society in New
York London and Beverly Hills among the
many celebrities he said to have parted
with included Lee rers and his sister
Jackie Kennedy Onasis princess margara
Andy Warhol Bianca Jagger and Elizabeth
Taylor he seems to thrive on little more
than drugs alcohol gossip and
controversy gleefully feuded with some
of these celebrities he hung out with
including most famously author gadal who
once said of him Truman Capote has made
lying an art and minor art Capote
responded in kind with a comment of
course I'm always sad about Gore very
sad that he has to breathe every day the
feud continued all the way until
capote's death which Vidal described to
a press reporter as and I quote a wise
career move by the end of his life
Capote had made being a celebrties
pretty much the sole focus of his career
having not published really anything but
a few essays since the appearance of
inob blood in 1966 yet he remained one
of the major literary influencers of the
late 20th century in 1968 Trum M Capote
sat for an extensive interview with
Playboy magazine yes the magazine really
did do articles that people read it for
during the course of the interview which
covered that Year's presidential
election the Civil Rights Movement the
war in Vietnam and his fellow writers
and artists Playboy asked him are there
any writers on the current literary
scene whom you consider to be truly
great Capote thought for a moment and
responded Yes Truman Capote he then
listed several others he considered
commendable gadal was not among them and
nonone ranked equally to him at least in
his
estimation
Truman Capote was given the name of
Truman stus persons following his birth
in New Orleans Louisiana in September
30th 1924 when he was 2 years old he was
sens with distant relatives on his
mother's side of the family when his
parents divorced it ended his
relationship with his biological father
and led to a long separation from his
own mother he was raised by Nanny folk
who Truman tooked to calling Suk in
Monroeville Alabama there he was
befriended by the Lee family headed by
an influential Monroeville lawyer named
amasa Truman became particularly close
with the longest ye child now harp yes
that harp both children had taught
themselves to read before entering
formal schooling and both enjoyed
reading and writing Nell Lee later
modeled the character of Dill in her
novel To Kill a Mocking Bird on her
childhood friend Truman used Nell as a
basis for the other character idel
Tomkins in his first novel or the voices
of the rooms the two remained friends
for most of Truman's life until gossip
over each other's contributions to their
most famous works drove the wedge
between them Truman was a small
effeminate shy child being there who
avoided the Rough and Tumble play of
other boys his age again being there he
wrote short stories and essays on a
weekend trip to Mobile Alabama submitted
one of his early Works to a children's
writing contest he was already quite
serious about his writing and spent
several hours at it each day his short
story Old Miss Busy Body won the contest
it was a tale of an obese woman who
attempts to murder her child Truman was
just 7 years old at the time and
speaking of books Let's go into my own
collection for a moment shall we and
this is my favorite book thy own because
I bought it simply because I really
dislike the phrase do not judge a book
by its cover and I saw a book with a 3D
dinosaur on it called zrex and went hell
godamn yes and I'm not going to talk too
much about it I'm simply going to read
the U the blurb on the back and you tell
me if you would not bought this book for
the princely sum of one British pound
you're a 13-year-old boy on the run a
massive man eating monster is on your
tail an evil group with a plot to
destroy Humanity once you both dead or
alive there's only one way out you and
the monster have to work together
hell yeah that same year in 1932 Truman
was brought to New York City to live
with his mother and a new husband Jose
Garcia capot they settled at first in an
opulent Park Avenue Apartment
overlooking Central Park Capote was a
former Spanish Colonel who invested in
New York real estate who adopted Truman
and bestowed upon him his last name the
colonel was not available as a father
figure for very long and shortly after
Truman arrived in New York Jose was
arrested charged and convicted for
embezzlement mother and son were forced
to leave the Park Avenue apartment for
Less EXP ensive rooms first in Brooklyn
and then on the Riverside Drive in
Manhattan Truman enrolled at Trinity
College entering the fourth grade there
in 1933 and over the following three
years his grades dropped steadily though
they remained sufficient to pass him on
to the next level concerned over his
studies and his effeminate nature his
mother enrolled in St John's Military
Academy in osing New York in 1936 there
she again more or less abandoned him
Truman would later Rec that she visited
him at the school only twice and wrote I
would have been much happier if my
mother had just left me in Alabama in
193 39 the capot moved to Connecticut
where Truman attended Greenwich High
School there he wrote for the school
newspaper though he performed poorly in
studies not related to English and
composition two years later the capot
moved yet again back to New York and
Truman was enrolled in the Franklin
school a private institution now known
as the Dwight school he completed his
high school studies in 1942 while
attending Franklin Truman obtained a
part-time job working as a copy boy at
the New Yorker and editor in the
magazine descried his appearance thusly
small and frail in appearance he's less
than 5' three in height beardless and
possessing a high feminine voice so high
pitched it was said that the only thing
that could hear him were dogs and if
anyone has not heard Truman Capote speak
I highly recommend doing so and then go
watch that episode of The Simpsons with
the dental plan and he sounds weirdly
similar to like the guy with the Rey
voice and not saying I don't I'm not
want to make fun of the way people's
voice sounds given how I sound but just
I could not un heere how similar he
sounds to the guy in the dental plan
Simpsons episode who just keeps saying
nay he was like all all opposed nay like
who keeps saying that that guy he sounds
so much like him anyway throughout his
childhood during those times spent with
his mother Truman was tortured by his
clear homosexuality in attempts by his
mother teachers and counselors to cure
him of it yeah kind of suck about then
he registered such attempts coming to
resent them he did not openly admit that
he was homosexual but he opposed any
attempts to discuss his personality or
his sexual orientation when he dutifully
entered the draft in 1942 the army
rejected him as 4f according to Truman
this is because he was too
neurotic beginning in 1943 and
continuing throughout the World War II
years Truman wrote a series of short
stories which appeared in the major
literary and entertainment magazines of
the day his work gained the attention of
literary critics usually drawing praise
and demand as his stories grew
dissatisfied with short stories he
expressed a desire to spend his time and
attention on a fulllength feature novel
who was following the publication of his
short story Miriam which which appeared
in Mademoiselle in 1945 that Bennett Sur
the influential co-founder of Random
House offered Truman in advance to
complete a novel with $1,500 in hand
about $25,000 in today's money Truman
left New York and returned to
Monroeville to complete a novel he' been
working on titled summer Crossing set in
New York which of course you needed to
be in Monroeville to write about in
Monroeville Truman encountered
difficulties in completing the novel
while visiting childhood hauns he found
inspiration for an entirely new story
set in the south he set summer Crossing
aside and later claimed to have
destroyed the manuscripts in actuality
in 2004 The Unfinished manuscript was
found completed by editors and published
a critical Acclaim in 2006 truran began
his new novel In The Familiar
surroundings of Monroeville though he
did not complete it there in the course
of writing the novel he moved several
times first New Orleans then Saratoga
Springs New York and several other
locations eventually completing the work
in Nuki in Massachusetts he later
described the novel as
semi-autobiographical an attempt to
exercise demons childhood friends
appeared in the book most notably n
Harper Le in the form of a southern
tomboy idel Tomkins graduated the main
character a 13-year-old Joel Knox comes
to terms of his own homosexuality as a
tale unfolds he titled the work simply
or the voices or the rooms published by
Random House in 1948 it was heavily
promoted prior to its release and it
opened at number nine on the New York
Times bestseller list it remained on the
list for some nine weeks selling over
26,000 copies after its initial release
critics were widely impressed and
reviews were highly favorable both for
the story and for The Voice to the
writer Capote was compared favorably to
writers such as William Faulkner Oscar
wild and Eva Edgar Allan po the subject
matter of the book was not without its
controversy this was the 1940s after all
and the combination of favorable reviews
and tooo subject matter made trumac
Capote a huge success in literary
circles yet not all reviews were kind
George Davis a writer and editor
commented on the book I suppose somebody
had to write the fairy Huckleberry Finn
again this is the 1940s and stuff back
then sucks promotion of other voices
other rooms led to the beginning of
capote's lengthy Feud with G the doubt
as well as other writers he never
forgave George Davis for his comment and
eventually skewed him in an unfinished
novel and the Press though he was famous
in literary circles in those
pre-television days he remained
relatively unknown numerous
organizations including the Catholic
League of deceny and the Christian
Science monitor banned the book and
libraries across the country refused to
carry it on their shelves sure I'm glad
we passed the days like that eh we live
in more enlightened times where people
have access to knowledge and uh um works
from people whose experiences different
from their own speaking of which well
let's go to another book in my
collection show this one is called K9
core by Kenneth Von giren it's the
fourth in the SF Adventure series again
I bought this because they always say
never judge a book by its cover you tell
me you would not buy a book with a dog
fighting a velociraptor on the front
let's go the blurp first you party then
you die as a reward for yanking a giga
billionaire off a prison satellite Ray
Lin and his team earn a month's hour and
hour on the universe's Ultimate Party
Planet I should note that um Ray Lin's
team is a bunch of super smart dogs but
Neverland isn't all fun and games no
more than a few fleeting nanocs after
landfall Ray and the dogs find that the
play Planet simulated War Games become
murderously realistic at the push of a
programmer's buttons K9 core they are
the best freelance space Scouts in the
Galaxy genetically altered dogs with
enhanced senses and the gift of speech
they are baywolf grindall mamasan gwne
osma Robin Frodo simbat and taji they
stand together besides Lin a human
leader against any danger anywhere at
any cost and who says you can't get good
literature for again less than1 at a
charity
[Music]
shop trabot remained busy following the
success of other voices other rooms he
published a noela the Glass Harp in 1951
and the following year produced it as a
stage play in 1953 he co-wrote along
with producer and director John Huston
the script for the film Beat the Devil
the film start hrey Bogard and Jennifer
Jones Capote and Huston wrote the script
as the film was being shot producing the
next day script following shooting each
day the actors weren't given their lines
until just before their scenes were
performed this shall we say unusual
approach gave the film a camp quality at
least according to a review written
decades later by Fame critic Roger rebet
Capote then accompanied the Every Man's
opera on a cultural exchange tour of the
Soviet Union where they performed pori
and Bess Capote was sent on tour as a
reporter for the New Yorker which
originally printed his articles in two
installments in late 1955 and early 1956
respectively random house later
published the articles in a single
volume titled simply the muses are heard
this was capote's first work of a
journalistic nature and foreshadowed his
use of artistic license in a reported
piece which he later expanded on his
most famous work in Cold Blood but we'll
get to that in a moment in 1955 truma
Capote moved into a basement apartment
in Brooklyn Heights in a large Greek
Revival house owned by a Broadway set
designer he was in that apartment where
he wrote several of his later short
stories Breakfast at Tiffany's and In
Cold Blood blood several of his stories
appeared in magazines accompanied by
photographs of the author taken in his
home and visitors to his home were
frequently surprised to learn that he
occupied only the basement apartments
and he delighted in leaving the
impression that he actually owned the
entire house though he did not in 1958
capot published a noela and three short
stories in a combined volume titled
Breakfast at Tiffany's a short novel and
three short stories okay not very
creative there Capote these stories were
House of Flowers a diamond guitar and a
Christmas memory the latter being an
autobiographical story reflecting
capote's years living with his M's
relatives in Alabama during his early
life it has since become a holiday
classic recorded numerous times
including by Capote himself in 1959 the
story is subsequently being adapted for
the stage and television into a full
length Musical and a one act Opera yet
it was The noela Breakfast at Tiffany's
that Drew the most attention of
publication after reading the noela
author Norman maor said that Capote was
and I quote the most perfect writer of
my generation he writes the best
sentences word for word Rhythm upon
Rhythm maor predicted that breakfast at
Tiffany would become an quote once again
a small classic I'm sure none of these
things gave Capote a massive ego or
anything like that the Nolla provided
the title for a 1961 film starring
Audrey hebburn and George Peart although
it bore little resemblance to the actual
written story and I will be remiss if I
did not mention who's not mentioning the
script here Mickey Rooney and perhaps
his most famous role was Mr Yosi role
that the New York Times described as
colorfully exotic yeah Capote was
dismissive of the film and of Audrey
heurn depicting Holly goly he claims to
have base the character on a woman who
rented an apartment in the same
Brownstone as him in postwar New York
and that Holo likely was his personal
favorite of all of his fictional
characters despite all these hints and
years of fan speculation Capote never
revealed the actual inspiration for the
character preferring instead to let
people just guess I
[Music]
suppose he was living in Brooklyn when
he read an article in the November 16th
1959 edition of the New York times the
article which ran only with 300 words
described the unsolved murder of the
Clutter family in the small town of hul
Kansas the 's quote of a local sheriff
as claiming and I quote this is
apparently the case of a psychopathic
killer according to capote's later
telling of the tale he approached his
editors at the New Yorker proposing a
story based on a novelized telling of
the factual story others have disputed
this claim the editors offered Capote
the chance of covering the story or
another based in New York Capote was
aware enough of how he impressed people
meeting him for the first time as well
as the suspicions harbored by small town
Dennis for strangers particularly those
from big cities gaining the cooperation
for the residents of Hulen will be
difficult for just him alone so he asked
his longtime friend Nelly Harper Lee to
accompany him to Kansas Lee had been
living in New York since the late 1940s
but retained her southern accent and
mannerisms both of which had long since
been shed by Capote Lee agreed to
accompany Capote to Kansas they arrived
in hulc days after the funerals of the
two murdered cler family they visited
the scene of the murders ined Friends of
the family investigators business
acquaintances and former employees of
the Clutter Farm Capote took no notes
recorded on of his interviews Lee did
taking copious notes sketching the
murder scene and recorded a journal
summarizing each day's activities as
they researched the crime now how much
harp contributed to the research that
led to In Cold Blood has been debated
ever since capot himself would later
claim that he trained his memory to the
point he was and I quote a human
recording machine with a tested ability
to retain over 90% of what he was told
in a Playboy magazine and in other
Publications he claimed this ability
allowed him to communicate more
effectively with those that he
interviewed his wrapped attention
putting them at ease curiously he did
not reveal this extraordinary ability
until rumors of Lee's contributions to
the finished Works s through literary
circles in 1970s Capote responded to the
rumors in a sideways fashion relating
his version of the extensive research
that went into in cblood in the first
person singular and never mentioning
Hara Lee At All by the time in Cold
Blood was published he has spent six
years on the project which he excused by
claiming he been waiting for the case to
be resolved in the courts during the
interim he visited The Killers Richard
hicock and Perry Smith in prison and
became obsessed with Smith in a case of
sexual attraction which varies to a
degree depending on the source you
consult Capote attended that execution
by hanging in 1965 telling Playboy it
was the worst experience of my life
period first published as a four part
serial in the New Yorker beginning in
September 1965 In Cold Blood was an
immediate sensation it was published in
a book form in January 1966 and shot to
the top of bestseller lists around the
country capot claims to have created an
entirely new form of writing the
non-fiction novel it was neither the
first in the genre nor was it entirely
non-fiction later research and
commentary by those described in
capote's book challenged the veracity
from the very beginning although the
basic thread of the story was true to
the events as it said inside of the book
capot created conversations shifted
events in the timeline and descried
incidents which just never took place in
1966 while the book was still selling
well Esquire published an article by
Philip Tomkins which described the
author's conversation with some of the
hcom citizens that refuted capote's
version of events Jack Olson for example
a noted journalist who wrote extensively
in the True Crime genre was quoted in
esquite as saying capot completely
fabricated quotes and whole scenes even
the prosecutor who convicted hickcock
and Smith claim capote's version of the
story was at best misleading while the
book sold well reviews were often not so
kind the New Republic called Capote and
I quote the most outrageously overrated
stylist of our time Tom Wolf described
the book as the promise of gory details
and the withholding of them until the
end in 1967 a film version of inbl was
released based on capote's work later
films explored the relationship between
Smith and capot a subject ignored in
capote's book in the 1967 film
whisperings regarding the contributions
that Harpy did not receive credit for
began literary circles as the book was
still on bestseller list Trum M Capote
dedicated In Cold Blood to Harley and
Jack Dy his long time partner by this
point Lee was already internationally
famous as the author of te killer
mocking burden while she did acknowledge
having accompanied Capote to Kansas and
assisting in his research he did nothing
to further malicious rumors of being
more deeply involved in the book on his
part Capote simply ignored any queries
regarding Lee's contributions and
insisted the work was entirely his own
he also ignored rumors which circulated
around the same time that he had
assisted Lee in the writing of her novel
allowing them to continue to swirl
rather than deny them kote would later
be quoted as saying no one will ever
know what in blood took out of me it
scraped me right down to the marrow of
my bones it nearly killed me I think in
a way it did Kill
Me following the success of inbl Truman
Capote worked sporadically on some other
short stories essays and other novel
titled answered prayers which remained
unfinished as mentioned he became famous
as a celebrity hosting lavish parties
attending others and becoming a
fictional talk shows on television he
can always be relied on for a tar quote
delivered in his unmistakable lisping
draw when asked if he was happy he once
replied that he wasn't unhappy and only
imbe and sweet idiots wandering around
in the sunshines of spring days are
happy he referred to the American middle
classes quite famously as Hagrid who's a
longtime romantic partner with another
writer Jack dumpy though they maintain
separate homes in New York dumy later
wrote that one reason they did not live
together was to spare him the pain of
watching capote's descent in drug
addiction and alcoholism in the 1970s
capot purchased a home in Palm Springs
California and began to spend more time
there the effectively ending his
relationship with duny in 1972 Rolling
Stone magazine commissioned Capote to
cover that year's American tour by the
band The Rolling Stones Capote traveled
with the band during the tour which
gained considerable notoriety for his
extensive drug use and large parties of
groupies capote's demands for special
attention and services shall we say
aggravated some of the touring party and
Keith Richards is said to have
threatened Capote with physical violence
after the tour Capote refused to report
his observations and write the article
he was paid to do rather than return the
advance he instead granted an interview
with himself to the magazine conducted
by his good friend Andy
Warhol okay he made several attempts at
drug and alcohol rehabilitation to
little real effect in the early 1880s he
began to suffer hallucinations and
seizures he became something of a
recluse and during the summer of 1984 he
went to California staying at the B home
of Joan Carson the former wife of talk
show host Johnny Carson he died there on
August 25th 1984 reportedly of liver
disease most of his estate went to his
former lover with the Proviso that upon
dump his death the estate would be used
to create and fund The Truman Capote
charitable trust supporting both critics
and writers with grants scholarships and
awards his long Feud with G Vidal
continued to the very end with Capote
egging on Vidal with biting remarks oh I
couldn't care less he once said after
being informed of one of adal's
statements whatever Gore says about me I
think the same thing about him and to
end on a quote from the man himself and
once when asked to describe himself
Truman capot referred to Saint wouldn't
added but I'm not a saint yet I'm an
alcoholic I'm a drug addict I'm a
homosexual I'm a
genius so I hope everybody at home
enjoyed this video and found it
educational entertaining and informative
I certainly found the script to be all
three of those things and invite you to
follow the writer on social media if you
agree and while you're down there
clicking things why not leave a like or
comment with feedback suggestions or
ideas for future videos and as always
you can subscribe for more videos like
this
B